hi
in this video we are going to talk a
little bit more about routers and how
they relate to networking routers are
things that connect different small area
networks I want to give kind of a
metaphor for this so I'm a teacher I
work at a school let's say I have a
package that I need to get to somebody
that works in the district offices I
don't know where her office is exactly
but I know her name
I go to my secretary that would be this
is me this is my secretary
I go to my secretary I say hey I need to
get this to solid so it's district
office can you please help me out here
she'll say oh sure I don't know exactly
where her office is either but I know
how to get there I know the next step so
even though I didn't know the next step
she does so she goes on and sends it on
to the secretary of a district office
now that district office secretary has
no idea who I am or where I am but she
knows the end location what I'm trying
to get across here is each router only
has to know its own little network only
the stops right next to it it doesn't
have to know the whole internet just has
to know its own connections and it can
take information and say all right I
don't know exactly where that's going
but I'll pass it on to the right
direction
and that's really all it takes routers
can be different sizes different
capacities but what they do is just know
their own neighborhood take the
information and pass it on in the right
direction another really powerful thing
that we're going to get into a little
bit later is they don't have to have the
full package of information either if
this computer is trying to send
information all the way up here it might
get split up and go to two different
routers and that's okay the computers
are still going to know how to put that
information back together correctly now
the little pieces of information that
are sent are called packets packets are
actually little pieces of binary code
which I'm going to draw up here for you
all right so this is an example of what
a packet might look like it's just this
line that goes up and then down and up
and down and is either up or it's down
that is an electrical current so a
computer gets back and can translate
that into ones and zeros which we all
know is a binary code the way it does
that is it draws lines a certain just
apart basically and if it's up high it's
the one if it's down low it's a zero as
we discussed in previous videos this one
and zero business can really mean a
whole lot more fact it means everything
everything can be translated into one
zero so this is really powerful now
these little packets are sent across
through these routers and sometimes if
there's a file that's too large for one
packet it can be broken up into frames
or smaller little packets these packets
don't have to go the same route they go
whichever routes available whichever
fastest and since they have the end IP
address encoded into them all the
routers know where to send them when
they get to the end destination that
computer knows how to put it all
together